oh
yes
oh
is
hello everyone i'm clayton davis film
awards editor at variety welcome to this
conversation with parallel mothers
writer and director pedro maldovar hello
pedro and the
penelope cruz hello and i'd like to see
you nice to see you penelope uh
congratulations on a fantastic
performance in this film
and
can you speak about you know the scene
the clip that we just watched the scene
in question where you understood these
two characters uh and what they were
both going through
what i was feeling in that scene
it was really interesting because they
are preparing to give birth and in a way
i was feeling like that's what we had to
do with these characters we were we shot
that kind of
like at the beginning of the
of the schedule
uh really really early
maybe it was even the first week
um
it was
preparing
to what was coming in the weeks after
which was really scary
because everything happens to this woman
to janice um
really really challenging but
an incredible adrenaline
trip you know like i look back and i
remember it as an incredible experience
but i remember the fear shooting that
scene the fear of the character that is
gonna give birth they're alone for
different reasons they don't have a lot
of people in in their lives
um
janice is very happy to be welcoming a
baby
anna is terrified and doesn't really
want to but
what happens that day is gonna
keep them together for the rest of their
lives for
very peculiar reasons
but
everything was mixing the fear of the
character and the fear that i felt of
like oh my god
what
would we have to do in the following
months
but i love that feeling too
pedro can you talk about how you
constructed that in your screenplay
[Music]
um
what makes the scene so powerful is not
just what it's said it's what's not and
and expressed through your eyes both of
you as the way you look at each other
because i think you spoke to anna has
like
the fear of god in her eyes
um
and janice is is
looking confident but her situation is
just as unknown and her fear probably is
a lot more internalized did you discuss
with pedro or with molina about
expressing those emotions like even in
the silence well i had i had given birth
i have given birth twice so i know very
well what it is milena didn't but she
did a great amount of research
and and we had so many months of
rehearsal with pedro you know
talking about every single scene but
also doing every every
we did the whole script a few times
because we had so many months
the blessing of having all that time is
that everything was very clear in terms
of the intentions of every silence and
every
sentence and because of that
incredible amount of time that we had
with him
but janice is terrified to
is terrified too the thing is that she
sees somebody that is even in a more
vulnerable position at that place
and immediately she feels this
connection and this maternal instinct
towards ana's character
and and it just happens they they click
and it happens and they have no idea how
their lives are
the destiny
has so many incredible
plans for them
when you're uh i like the last like
maybe
uh four seconds of the clip because it
it moves outside the room and you guys
are walking in the hallway and like
walking around in labor and like the
world is just going on around you which
is just very symbolic of
parenthood
i think pedro showed that in an
incredible way even alberto's music
accompanies that feeling so well of
you're going into a limbo
and there is no way back but is the most
amazing limbo
but
you are about to get into the biggest
adventure of your life
on top of that it's like these two women
are not experiencing very stable
lives very stable situations
so
anyways like an
incredible
internal revolution but for them even
more because of what is about to happen
and because they are already
with a lot of pressure being totally
alone but not because they have chosen
to be alone just because of what has
happened to them and a lot of trauma
behind
yeah you know why
i i just
try
to represent something that i saw in
real life i mean when i was in making
the research or the movie
i went to a hospital and i went to the
to the section of maternity or that
hospital and i was very impressed when i
when i saw zach not exactly i mean there
were more women than in my movie
in that corridor i mean in silence
walking like a sleep worker without
going to to somewhere specific
and
it
the
it seems to me at the moment
that uh
that they were like in a kind of
translate
translates trans
trans
um
and
and in silence
so i tried to represent it when i when i
did
this this sequence
and then you know i mean thinking about
motherhood or maternity um they are in
their own reality
when i was shooting
there were many sequences that i that i
that i asked penelope because penelope
is a mother
and then then because then i realized
that even that i had made a lot of
researches
that i didn't know so many things about
little aspect of
to to being growing
a a child unfortunately there were many
women on the set uh beginning for the
the penelope and they were telling me
things about about about it
pedro my dear pedro i would like to ask
you
what would you have done
in johnny's place
if you
had a situation like that would you have
spoken the truth would you have
stayed quiet forever
and
you know i asked myself that too
and
i think in my case
i will suffer a lot
because um the situation
i mean she's not guilty of that
situation
but anyway
she has to take a decision about that
and then
i think that i could live
without
this guilt complex
during more time
than series
so
so my answer is that i will do the same
thing
that that as janice made in the movie
but i will
it will take me more time
to decide to tell the truth
um
yeah i think like i think that
it is
morally it's a difficult question
because
uh you know is that it's a little mean
not to say to the other person which is
as close to you the truth about about
that child
but but i but i can understand that
is
and in any case you know make the
character of janine's richer
more difficult to act and but
more interesting and more complex
so i mean in a narrative way i mean just
thinking about the script
uh the character is much more complex
because of that
this is definitely one of your most
beautiful movies which says a lot
because your movies are always so so
amazing can you talk about the colors on
the wall in the room in the scene and
what what they mean uh to the characters
and to how you constructed it well if
you don't mean the real colors in the
hospital
they used to be like a
white
or
a kind of gray
and then on the
i mean i don't like white white
in a movie
uh i mean yes the background if he's
white is too tough
um and then i
i mean i forget reality
and as you know that i that i like
bright colors i decided for these two
colors
not to how could i say too outrageous
but
they are they are colors that they don't
use
usually they don't they don't they don't
use in in the hospital but i i decided
because they were warmer with the with
the two girls there i mean
the
yellow and the
on the green tower
the tower blue
and
[Music]
is they are much more i mean also they
belong to my palette of colors
but also they are like quieter
colors for the sequences penelope was
this perfect timing for you to play
this role of janice like having that
new kind of outlook on
life and being a mother
i've always had a very strong maternal
instinct
and
when i look back at vulvar for example i
was not a mother then but i i could
understand
the the threat that this woman goes
through
the
the the pain of that extreme situation
of domestic violence you know and i
didn't have
to go through that either in my life to
understand what a woman in that
situation can feel
and that is the beauty of this
profession that i mean
we just have to
100 go there with
research and with our imagination and
when you're in that moment in that scene
like
really go there and
don't without being afraid of
experiencing that pain because the
safety is that you are
you are
fortunately working with a fiction but
but you're gonna do it from a layer up
here so that you don't suffer you have
to go in to honor
uh
the the people and the situations that
are unfortunately are not fiction so
that is always my safety net is like no
go there because there is a there are
women somewhere right now that are going
through that situation
and in that way it doesn't become
it's not something about you it's not
something about your ego it's not
something about your fear it's not it's
like just one way to do it you have to
go through that and experience for
minutes for for four seconds or four
hours in that day or whatever days it
takes
what it would be to have a life like
that or to have a situation like that i
love it so much and i think if we were
having this conversation when i'm 90 i
would be saying exactly the same things
because it's always something new
is the most fascinating thing about
that is why i love acting so much
absolutely
is
i'm conscious that i
that now i'm like like like like at the
beginning like like in a hurry
i mean i i really need to make more
movies than before and i think this is
because i mean capacity of time
that i
and actually i mean the last two years
uh with the lockdown i i i work more
than more than ever i mean i i wrote
this this script
after i
i i shoot a short movie with tilda
shinton i prepared this movie
and now at the same time that i'm making
the promotion
also i'm
working on at least the next two
projects i don't know why it seems to me
that i don't have time or i don't know
that i that i'm
i feel more in a hurry to do to make
movies so
yes yes yes i will i will keep on making
movies when penelope will be 19.
that
and it's good because at that moment i
will be also very old so i will i will
write a character for this kind of
people
thank you pedro pedro maldovar and
penelope cruz for joining us for this
conversation today again i'm clayton
davis film awards editor at variety
and we'll see you soon thank you thank
you later thank you